من ناحيه الهزات الارتداديه اول شيء يعني
ايش الفرق بين الهزات الارتداديه هذه
والزلازل
في الواقع الهزه الابتداديه هي زلزال انما
حصل في سياق زلزال اكبر منه في نفس
المنطقه اللي حصل فيها يعني ما بنستطيع
نقول انه حصل زلزال في تركيا وحصلت لهزه
ارتداديه في على سبيل المثال لبنان في
الجغرافيا المنطقه بتكون محدده عمليا
عشرات الكيلومترات اذا كانت زلزال كبير
جدا كما هو الحال هنا يعني يمكن ان نعتبر
هذا على نفس الصدع بنفس البيئه هو عباره
عن هزه ارضيه بتكون عمليا هدفها اعاده
التوازن للمنطقه لانها عندما يحصل بها
زلزال كبير بتكون قد اضطربت بشكل كبير جدا
وفقدت التوازن يعني نفس الغلاف الصخري
فبصير في عندنا يعني رغبه او عمليا اتجاه
لاعاده توازن بالهزات الارتداديه في نفس
المنطقه اللي حصلت فيها الزلازل الاولى
لكن زلزال كبير كهذا هذه المنطقه تحدد
يعني بعشرات الكيلومترات على نفس الصدى
لاي درجه بتكون الهزات خطيره
خطوره الهزات يعني بتعتمد اساسا على ايضا
البناء ونوعه الاستعداد وما شابه ذلك في
بعض زلازل كبرى اكبر اكبر من هذا في تشيلي
مثلا
ثمانيه واثنين بالعشره كان عدد القتلى
قليل جدا اثنين ولا ثلاثه لكن في مناطق
اخرى من العالم العربي للاسف الشديد اربعه
ونص زلزال بسيط جدا يعني قد يقتل عشر
اشخاص
هذا الزلزال عمليا عالميا زلزال 87
بالعشره في منطقه ماهوله مدن مليونيه
بتكون خسائر بعشرات احب اسالك عن الهزات
الجداديه هل ممكن تكون يعني
الدمار اللي تعمله اسوا يكون من الزلزال
نفسه اللي حتى لدرجه انه نتلخبط بينها
وبين الزلزال
طبعا هذا ممكن رغم ان الهزه الارتداديه
قوتها بالتعريف اقل من الهزه الرئيسيه لكن
عندما يحصل زلزال كبير فهو يهلهل كم كبير
جدا من الابنيه اذا جاءت ضربه اضافيه حتى
وان كانت اضعف من الاولى فتؤدي الى انهيار
ما تبقى يعني من اماكن وقد يكون الدمار
برضو كبير في هذا المجال لانه الابنيه
تهلهلت سابقا واصبحت ضعيفه طيب تم الحديث
عن وجود زلزال ثاني او حدوث زلزال ثاني
اللي هو كان سبعه فاصله خمسه هذا زلزال
يعتبر اخر ولا هزه ارتداديه
الاحتمال الاكبر خاصه اذا كان مكانه يعني
يبعد نسبيا عن هذا المكان ان يكون اشي
مستقل لانه الهزات الارتداديه يعني
علاقات التجريبيه في علم الزلازل بتقول
المفروض يكون في فرق تقريبا واحد واحد
واثنين بالعشره درجه
تكون الهزه الارتداديه اقل من الهزه
الرئيسه لكن هذا برضو هنالك استثناءات
والعلاقه التجريبيه احيانا قد تفشل فما
يحدد انه هز ارتداديه ولا هذه رئيسيه هو
الموقع والظروف واليه الزلزال يمكن حسابها
بواسطه علم الزلازل فيما بعد الانترنت
مليان بالحديث عن تسونامي قادم
ردك على هذا الموضوع
طبعا تسونامي في الواقع يعني ارتفاع مستوى
مياه البحر ومهاجمتها مثلا الشواطئ هذا
يمكن رصده بشكل جيد ولا يمكن التكهم به
جزافا بهذا الشكل في انظمه نظام انذار
مبكر للتسونامي تعتمد على انه يكون هنالك
طوافات في البحر تحدد احداثياته وتحدد
ارتفاعاتها اذا بالاقمار الصناعيه اكتشف
انه فجاه جبهه كبيره من المياه ارتفعت
وهذا يمكن تحديده يعلن انه في هنالك
تسونامي والا يعني لا نستطيع ان نقول انه
تسونامي طبعا تسونامي من من مميزاته
الحميده بانه يعطي وقت قد ياتي بعد ساعات
بعد
يعني فتره طويله وليس كالزلزال لحظي
ومفاجئ